buongiorno a tutti appunto sono lorenzo
santini e ho 22 anni e
ok
scusate l'emozione e
io sono qui vorrei raccontarvi la storia
di una persona che ha deciso di crearsi
un opportunità all opportunità
lavorativa cioè ma soprattutto una
persona che ha creduto e ha dato alla
voglia di fare non soltanto mia ma di
tutte le persone che mi hanno dato umano
tra cui colleghi ma anche la mia
famiglia infatti io sono il cofondatore
appunto insieme al mio fratello di una
start up di firenze che realizza e
progetti stampanti tridimensionali a
basso costo ed open source
e prima cosa che cos'è una stampante
tridimensionale e come funziona una
stampante 3d è una macchina in grado di
materializzare un oggetto infatti si
parte da un disegno 3d che può essere
reperito su internet o può essere
disegnato tramite un programma cad e poi
tramite un software presente sul
computer lo si converte in un linguaggio
che verrà poi elaborato dalla macchina
stessa e la macchina sciogliendo un filo
di plastica lo deposita strato su strato
fino a realizzare un oggetto un po sì
forse un po di magia c'è anche questa
tecnologia qua e ma per spiegare ancora
meglio come funziona una stampante
tridimensionale
provate a immaginare di avere nelle
vostre mani un ananas di dividerla
affette e poi di ricostruire l'anas
vestendo una fetta sopra un'altra fetta
ed è così che funziona la stampante
tridimensionale
ma quello che noi oggi facciamo non
sarebbe stato possibile senza questo
progetto che il progetto reprap che è un
progetto open source nato in inghilterra
che aveva come finalità la divulgazione
delle conoscenze necessarie per la
realizzazione di appunto di una
stampante tridimensionale a basso costo
ed open source e questo progetto è stato
ideato da questo signore qua il
professore dell'università di bath
adrian boyer il quale ipotizzò una
macchina in continua evoluzione nel
senso in grado di evolversi crescere ma
soprattutto anche in grado di replicare
alcune delle componenti che la formavano
infatti le stampanti 3d che noi
produciamo hanno parti plastiche che
vengono prodotte da altre stampanti 3d
macchine che creano altre macchine un po
alla terminator per questo in questo
modo ma il progetto re tratto appunto
come ho detto all'inizio era un progetto
o meglio è ancora un progetto open
source e questo ha permesso in pochi
anni di divulgarsi di svilupparsi di
arricchirsi tant'è che noi stessi
abbiamo dato il nostro contributo a
questo progetto sviluppando un nostro
modello di stampante tridimensionale che
abbiamo nominato in onore del di uno
scienziato omonimo toscano galileo che è
un
vengo da firenze
ma torniamo alla foto di famiglia
appunto alcuni dei membri che formano
che strapperà sono proprio dei miei
familiari e secondo me c'è un aspetto
molto importante in questa in questa
foto ma in senso in questo contesto
ovvero tre generazioni di artigiani che
lavorano insieme per creare qualcosa che
a metà tra il replicator di star trek è
un prodotto artigianale perché beh e lo
dico con molta gioia e con molta enfasi
ogni nostra stampante viene prodotta
artigianalmente
siamo noi che tagliamo i pezzi li
puliamo li assembliamo insomma è un
prodotto artigianale al cento per cento
e questo il modo in cui abbiamo lavorato
finora con mio fratello che si occupa
delle componenti elettroniche in fin dei
conti è l'unica ingegnere elettronico
che attualmente abbiamo poi c'è mio
padre che si occupa delle parti
meccaniche e c'è pure anche il nostro
cugino cucina e zio che ci danno una
mano nell'assemblaggio delle stampanti
ma non è finita qua abbiamo in volto
pure nostro nonno che
con tanto di mascherina si occupa di
rifinire le parti plastiche che
compongono le stampanti e est il nostro
nonno a 77 anni aggiungerei suonati e è
sempre stato un artigiano e secondo me è
straordinario pensare al fatto che
quando il nostro nonno ha iniziato a
lavorare da artigiani a firenze molto
probabilmente viene ancora delle
botteghe artigiane e oggi a quella che
viene definita da molti l'alba della
terza rivoluzione industriale
i suoi nipoti stanno anch'essi lavorando
da artigiani o meglio da artigiani
tecnologici in una parola makers ma
qualche tempo fa è successo qualcosa di
interessante all'auto di nostro nonno si
era rotta una componente questo gancetto
che vedete che teneva unita la
cappelliera al portabagagli e si tratta
di un pezzo insignificante se voi avete
presente tutte le componenti che formano
un automobile o meglio insignificante
fino a quando non si rompe perché
non so quanti di voi sarebbero in grado
di dirmi o di dire dove poter reperire
questo pezzo di ricambio
e noi dopo alcune ricerche ancora non
siamo in grado di dirlo ma quindi
secondo me il discorso è tutt'altro che
banale e potremmo riassumere in una
domanda che cosa succede quando le cose
si rompono
beh secondo la nostra esigenza
esperienza possono accadere tre cose la
prima è che vi sia da cambiare tutta la
parte la seconda è quella che piace a
noi ovvero il fai da te
in questo caso potrebbe essere se uno
alle competenze e le capacità di farlo
potrebbe ripararlo ma non sempre è così
e infatti il risultato in molti casi è
diverso da quello che ci aspettiamo la
terza soluzione che vi sia da sostituire
tutta la parte
ma questo discorso aveva veramente
iniziato a interessarci e quindi abbiamo
deciso di compiere una piccola
esplorazione del quotidiano ovvero cioè
cercare tutti quegli oggetti che noi
utilizziamo quotidianamente ma che se si
rompono sono destinati ad essere gettati
via e abbiamo trovato un sacco di
oggetti che possono essere avere lo
stesso destino e quindi ci siamo chiesti
ma forse la terza rivoluzione
industriale può iniziare anche da qui
ovvero se noi fossimo in grado di
riparare alcuni degli oggetti che
utilizziamo quotidianamente non saremmo
forse più ricchi beh alla fine il pezzo
è stato disegnato lo abbiamo stampato e
abbiamo riparato l'auto del nostro nonno
ma questo stesso pezzo oggi grazie a
internet potrebbe essere condiviso
online diffuso in qualsiasi parte del
mondo e un altro utente che si trova ad
affrontare lo stesso esatto problema
potrebbe utilizzarlo e riparare la sua
automobile ma associare la stampa o
meglio la tecnologia di stampa
tridimensionale solo all'idea di potersi
riparare un oggetto sarebbe riduttivo
e infatti la stampa tridimensionale è
una tecnologia incredibile che ha un
grandissimo potenziale perché ma perché
permette di materializzare un idea voi
pensate a ciò che potete avere in mente
e avere qualcosa che vi permette di
realizzarlo quindi si tratta di
materializzare un sogno un'idea una
fantasia e questo oggetto cremano è un
oggetto che è stato stampato ma è un
giocattolo ma in realtà racchiude al suo
interno qualcosa di più complesso
infatti la macchina l'ha creato con una
cavità al suo interno vuota e ora vi
spiego il suo funzionamento
è purtroppo non c'è clip
ma questo è soltanto una delle tutte le
possibili oggetti si possono stampare e
vediamo alcuni degli oggetti che sono a
mio avviso veramente belli e
spettacolari
per esempio abbiamo il caso di queste
cuffie che sono state interamente
stampate ad eccezione della parte
elettrica e quindi questo permette
all'utente di poter customizzare cioè
personalizzare le proprie cuffie un
oggetto che uno può utilizzare anche
quotidianamente ma c'è un altro progetto
molto interessante che questo progetto
qua il progetto di un braccio robotico
interamente stampato e il suo creatore
non soltanto ha messo a disposizione di
tutti i file tridimensionali ma anche le
conoscenze le istruzioni per poterlo
assemblare e così si è creata una
commissione che intorno a questo
progetto che ha sviluppato condiviso e
creato nuove parti e nuove possibili
applicazioni di questo braccio
ma c'è un altro progetto che stiamo
cercando di portare avanti da un po di
tempo ed è un progetto volto alla
divulgazione della tecnologia di stampa
tridimensionale all'interno degli
istituti ci siamo stati chiamati dall
istituto tecnico di catanzaro scalfaro
quindi da firenze siamo partiti per
catanzaro e siamo andati a presentare la
nostra stampante tridimensionale
nel giro di un quarto d'ora e nell'aula
c'erano circa 350 studenti che hanno
accerchiato il mio fratello cercando di
capire come funzionava e quindi ci siamo
accorti di come questa tecnologia possa
invogliare giovani menti studenti
ragazzi ma
studenti appunto ragazzi giovani menti
perché perché può dare la possibilità
appunto di materializzare un idea di
creare qualcosa e qualcuno ha nella sua
testa di poterlo toccare con mano e
infatti nel giro di una settimana
il professor talarico la sua classe ha
realizzato un progetto da stampare che
il progetto di un ladytron un
dispositivo per la levitazione magnetica
in una settimana
ma non è finita qua infatti siamo stati
contattati anche da
artigiani designer professionisti
studenti e alcuni di questi designer
hanno comprato una nostra stampante e
insieme a degli artigiani noti italiani
hanno realizzato una mostra in cui hanno
utilizzato la nostra stampante per poter
realizzare oggetti della mostra e quando
ci hanno chiamato a visionare quello che
avevano fatto noi sì ci siamo rimasti il
proprio di stucco perché non credevamo
che si potesse arrivare a stampare
all'inizio cioè con una nostro primo
prototipo di macchina degli oggetti del
genere è stata veramente una sorpresa
incredibile se siamo rimasti nell'arte a
bocca aperta perché poi gli oggetti
avevano parti molto complesse da
portacandele addirittura il ramo stesso
di quella di quel tronchetto di albero è
stato interamente stampato incredibile
ma
quindi ricapitolando e per concludere
siamo stati contattati da studenti
ingegneri artigiani e tutte quelle
persone che sono venute poi a trovarci e
che ci chiedevano ma come si usa una
stampante di che cosa si può fare con la
stampante 3d noi ancora non abbiamo mai
dato una risposta negativa nel senso non
abbiamo non ci è mai capitato di dire
questo oggetto non si può stampare anche
perché sostanzialmente quando qualcuno
ti chiede se si può fare o no subito
dopo si inizia a stampare grazie a tutti